en france l'avenir d'un petit village
comme le nôtre s'intéresse personne
s'est fait une demande de subvention
pour reprend vers tire notre usine est
en laye on a un mois pour que le docteur
maxime meyer tombe amoureux de saint
ouen la moderne
parce que si le docteur signe bruxelles
sin et on a notre usine 30 village de
mer on a une semaine pour faire de ces
nous le plus beau village de france
voilà on n'est pas bien là en arrivant
au village
il faut qu'ils aient un vrai coup de
foudre sans sympa faudra jouer au
village partir faudrait être impeccable
vous avez ce qu'on appelle un peu
d'athlètes merci alors vous emballez pas
c'est un champignon
le cauchemar a en fait se trouve futurs
docteurs est un grand fan de cricket est
dans la merde ça va être exactement la
même tenue que les jours de cliquer bon
jouer au cricket par ici par toutes les
ruses et même le grand coeur de pékin
alors bien sûr il va falloir trouver
quelque chose pour la protéger c'est pas
ça c'est pas ta verra si tu restes tu
finiras par adorer la pêche enfin ça
m'étonnerait il ya faute là bonjour
mais quand même bien ici et pourquoi tu
ne lui demande pas simplement d'être et
notre docteur jeu beau bar de ligne sans
mensonges et samaa rougissant tout ça
mais tout froid a touché quasiment
congelés est quelque chose de
particulier quelque chose contre spoil
vous est vrai
j'adore mon village c'est peut-être pas
le plus beau village de france mais
c'est l'ennemi
ce que tu as oublié de 9 à 6 pour
emporter la sphère j'ai dû promettre la
virginité de filles à un fonctionnaire
de bruce sohn quoi mais pourquoi ma
fille d'école ça fait longtemps que les
pillards